[Musique]
salut bonjour bienvenue dans questions
sénateurs votre émission hebdomadaire de
public sénat et d'acropolis on reçoit un
sénateur une sénatrice chaque semaine
pour répondre à vos questions et cette
semaine on a le plaisir de recevoir
cécile cukierman bonjour bonjour vous
entendez bien tout va bien je vous
entends très très bien j'espère que la
réciproque est vraie c'est super tout se
passe très bien c'est parfait on va
passer une heure ensemble avec vous
c'est si luc hermann je précise que vous
étiez matrice communiste de la loire et
on va apprendre à vous connaître on va
parler d'actualité du sénat de votre
actualité
et puis globalement de l'actualité
politique qui en ce moment est
particulièrement chargé bonjour à vous
qui vous qui nous regardent et c'est
vous qui allez échangé avec avec cécile
mme karman est là pour répondre à vos
questions et aux questions que j'ai
préparé avec vous un bon jour si vous ne
regardez actuellement sur twitter
bonjour si vous regardez en replay sur
public sénat le canal 13 de la tnt et
bonjour à vous si vous renoncez qui si
vous nous écoutez aussi en podcast on va
parler de vous mais d'abord je voudrais
qu'on aborde un sujet d'actualité chaude
si je puis dire c'est la sphère kohler
la pierre kohler qui ne qui redémarre
avec un nouveau rebondissement le la le
parquet national financière et ouvre une
enquête sur le possible conflit
d'intérêts j'ai secrétaire général de
l'elysée on se souvient que le parc
national financier avait abandonné les
poursuites et on a appris grâce à
mediapart cette semaine que c'était
suite à la réception d'une note signée
par emmanuel macron lui-même levée de
boucliers tollé dans l'opposition
est ce que vous aussi vous redoutez des
pressions de l'elysée sur le parquet bah
écoute et inévitablement vous savez dans
ce genre d'affaires alors d'une
évidemment la justice tranchera et je ne
suis pas là pour faire la justice mais
il ya toujours eu quand même quelques
interrogations se sont effectivement a
priori deux personnes à ses proches qui
se connaissaient donc inévitablement on
voit bien dans cette affaire
malheureusement comme dans d'autres
elles sont assez rares celles ci sont
publiques et nous donne pas en tout cas
tout ce qu'il faudrait de belles images
j'ai envie de dire
la politique mais je crois qu'on est là
en tout cas avec ce gouvernement avec
ceux présents la république dans un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont
énormément d'amis haut placés dans les
affaires et donc inévitablement je pense
des conflits d'intérêts qui peuvent se
répéter
alors je vais juste attendre deux
minutes parce qu'à part manger après le
décompte de mon côté c'est pas le bon
micro qui marche
j'ai un très bon au micro devant la
bouche mais apparemment c'est le micro
de la webcam qui pense aux et du cou
ouais effectivement et le micro et ouais
je sais pas beaucoup et ma mission au
micro la incroyable est-ce que c'est
mieux maintenant
alors bougez pas jouer on va la refaire
les missions en refaire un lancement
c'était un fou des phares c'est au tour
de chauffe ça pour toi bien bouger
parfait
normalement tu es mieux incroyable bond
à chocques aux risques doivent être
diffusés à la tnt ensuite mixé na waie
ont refait un bon lancement de mon intro
et on passe la méthode voilà les gens
surpris que ça ne vous savez rien c'est
partir fait nous le lancement match te
plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
tout
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans questions aux sénateurs
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
d'acropolis et de public sénat où on
reçoit un sénateur ou une sénatrice pour
répondre à vos questions
cette semaine on a le plaisir de
recevoir cécile cukierman sénatrice
communiste de la loire bonjour vous
m'entendez bien bonjour je vous entends
très bien eh ben c'est super c'est
parfait on va passer une heure ensemble
on va apprendre à vous connaître et on
va parler avec vous de votre travail au
sénat et des grands sujets d'actualité
politique qui en ce moment sont assez
nombreux bonjour à vous si vous nous
regardez sur twitter actuellement
bonjour à vous si vous nous regardez
henry placent sur public sénat le canal
13 de la tnt et bonjour aussi à vous si
vous nous écoutez en podcast c'est vous
qui allez poser vos questions à cécile
kerman c'est vous qui interagissent avec
on l'a tout de suite dans le chat etc
vos questions que que j'ai fait remonter
tout à l'heure pour préparer cette
émission on va parler de vous ces
circuits kerman mais avant ça je
voudrais qu'on aborde un sujet un sujet
d'actualité chaude si je puis dire cette
semaine on a appris la réouverture de la
procédure dans le cadre de la sphère
kohler le secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée qui va donc à nouveau être
poursuivi par le parquet national
financier parc national financier qui
avait abandonné une première fois les
poursuites et on l'a appris par
mediapart s'était suite à l'arrivée
d'une note rédigée par le président de
la république ne lui même pardon ça
prend ça provoque un tollé dans
l'opposition dans les oppositions
emmanuel macron est soupçonné d'avoir
fait pression sur le parquet est-ce que
vous aussi vous craignez cette pression
va écouter oui cette pression on l'a
enfin parce que d'abord il semblerait
que non actuellement elle soit démontrée
après voilà je ne suis pas la justice il
ne parviendra pas de faire justice ici
le parquet financier ré ouvre en tout
état de cause ça pose bien évidemment
toute la question des conflits d'intérêt
de ce gouvernement de ce présent la
république qui ont énormément d'amis à
la tête des affaires est en tout cas
dans cette histoire là effectivement
d'un ami qui a été dans une boîte privée
qui aujourd'hui à travailler à l'elysée
et on sent bien toute cette collusion
qui n'est certainement pas bon alors je
tiens à dire ce genre d'affaires ne sont
pas les plus frais
et malheureusement quand elle arrive
elle donne ça l'image en tout cas de la
vie politique française
alors il yal'affaire koller qui de son
côté donc va peut-être un jour être jugé
en tout cas le parquet réouvre son
enquête mais ya la question du parquet
lui-même et c'est ça aussi qui est
institutionnellement est
particulièrement intéressant à regarder
le parquet national financier est-il un
parquet à la botte du pouvoir
c'est quelque chose qui est reproché par
par certains opposants oui je suis
sénatrice et que je demande clairement
cette indépendance du parquet
généralement tous les présidents de la
république sont élus en nous promettant
une réforme constitutionnelle qui
viserait justement à assurer cette
indépendance comme ça et le cas
d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays un tout
simplement pour que tout le monde
comprenne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le
parquet le procureur eh bien peut
recevoir effectivement des notes des
recommandations que la part de la garde
des sceaux de la ministre de la justice
et donc il ya toujours cette incertitude
quant à l'indépendance réelle du
procureur par rapport aux magistrats à
ce 8 juin dernier
il y à une urgence je crois et cette
affaire le dépôt comme d'autres avant et
malheureusement comme d'autres à venir
si on ne fait rien kylie a besoin
clairement de procureur indépendant du
pouvoir et qui n'est pas à donner à
rendre des comptes à recevoir des
recommandations de la part du pouvoir
alors ces recommandations quand même
évolué puisque christiane taubira
l'ancienne garde des sceaux avait mis
fin aux consignes individuelles dans un
dossier en particulier elle avait donné
seulement des instructions générales ce
qui a été conservé par la suite mais
visiblement ça va pas assez loin
bah écoute et non vous savez les
instructions générales qu'on ne voulait
fête au parc aussi financier ils ne sont
quand même pas si nombreux que ça cela
continue ça existe et je vous dis quoi
je crois que compris au delà de vivre au
quotidien dans le rapport des françaises
et français à la justice si l'on veut
réellement une justice indépendante et
bien il faut éviter tout soupçon de lien
entre le pouvoir et la justice y aurait
donc la meilleure solution c'est
d'empêcher effectivement qui dialogue
possible entre le pouvoir en place et
celles et ceux qui rendent justice alors
à cette question-là l'actuelle garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet
rétorque que couper totalement le lien
entre le pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
et le parquet c'est faire une croix sur
toute politique possible est ce
qu'un parc est totalement indépendant
c'est pas le risque simplement que la
justice fonctionne en vase clos et qui
ne et qu'on puisse pu mener une
politique pénale
qu'est ce que vous répondez à l'église
de justice ça me fait sourire
je trouve exceptionnel quand même la
politique pénale oui c'est toujours ça
que la politique pénale
elle est aussi le produit de la loire
jusqu'à nouvel ordre ce sont les
parlementaires qui font la loi dans ce
pays
donc voilà c'est les petits privilèges
certes du gouvernement de garder ce lien
intrinsèque entre le parquet et eux
mêmes
je crois il ya quelques années quand
j'étais professeur d'histoire-géographie
j'enseignais la séparation des pouvoirs
qui est un principe je crois important
et donc oui on doit le plus le mieux
possible garantir cette indépendance
entrons pouvoirs judiciaire exécutif et
législatif est une des garanties et
celle ci l'arrêt de ce lien entre celui
qui est le procureur dans une affaire et
le ministre de la justice le ou la
ministre de la justice
est-ce que vous pensez que macro on va
être particulièrement inquiété par cette
affaire là parce que là ça on touche au
coeur de l'elysée quand même c'est le
secrétaire général de l'elysée c'est le
président de la république qui signe lui
même on est sur un très très haut niveau
de la honte
on est sur des questions effectivement
très personnelle je crois que pour le
coup et je le redis parce que je viens
de dire que j'étais attaché à
l'indépendance de la justice rendra
justice dans cette dans cette affaire
donc voilà mais si bien évidemment les
faits sont constatées oui cela mettre en
difficulté le président de la république
et après on y reviendra peut-être à
travers d'autres questions il n'y a pas
que ça est toute la question pour mettre
en difficulté quelqu'un est aussi quelle
alternative politique il ya en face lyon
horreur du vide
on reparlera de ça avec vous est
d'ailleurs en parlant de vous on va
faire votre portrait cécile cukierman
qui êtes-vous d'où venez vous vous êtes
né à bagneux et vous avez eu votre bac
aso ce que j'ai trouvé sur la page
wikipédia je peux vous mentir vous avez
grandi en région parisienne oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes élu le pays
de nos jours on est on est on grandit on
travaille ailleurs finir mes études à
m'installer dans la loire il pas ses
mots pour cours pour devenir enseignante
et puis ensuite avoir un certain nombre
de mandats dans mon département et la
région
alors vous avez eu votre bac littéraire
en 94 et vous avez souhaité ensuite
faire des études littéraires des études
d'histoire vous vouliez déjà devenir
prof
oui le fois ma vie était plutôt celui ci
que celui d'aujourd'hui n'avait pas en
tout cas de projet à devenir
parlementaire est en tout cas en formant
sénatrice et je crois comme beaucoup de
jeunes à l'époque de 18 19 ans certes je
savais ce que c'était que être que senna
mais ce n'était pas en tout cas
l'objectif de 9
c'est ce que j'ai demandé c'est rarement
blessé ne disent jamais jeux à 17 ans je
rêvais de devenir sénateur ou sénatrice
est rare bon d'accord mère du coup on va
raconter l'histoire de comment ça s'est
passé jusqu'à jusqu'à ce moment là mais
quand même un truc qu'on a noté que les
internautes ont voté vous avez eu votre
bac en 94 et votre maîtrise d'histoire
en 2001
pourquoi vous avez mis sept ans à avoir
un bac + 4 parce que d'abord j'ai fait
un deux un dogue a dit sue et puis j'ai
fait ma maîtrise vous étiez très engagé
quand vous êtes étudiante quand vous
étiez étudiante j'ai vu adhésion à
l'unef alors raconté racontez-nous ses
années étudiantes là comment comment
est-ce qu'on adhère à l'unef quand on
est étudiant à ce moment là bas on est à
une toute autre époque
u9 de mon époque n'est peut-être pas
tout à fait c'est d'ailleurs celle
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il y avait
plusieurs organisations syndicales
étudiantes savez moi je suis arrivé à
l'université il y avait le mouvement de
novembre décembre 95 qui avait été une
forte mobilisation à la fois sur les
conditions de travail au départ dans les
universités justement moi j'ai connu ses
amphis surchargés bondée où il fallait
arriver en avance je vais avoir de la
place pour s'asseoir derrière le chaises
et une table
donc voilà il ya eu cette première
mobilisation puis ensuite s'en est
suivie effectivement la mobilisation du
monde des salariés sur la réforme de la
sécurité sociale
voilà et puis après tout la situation
effectivement étudiante qui était une
époque où se poursuivaient cette
massification sert de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui avaient le de lycéens
qui avaient le baccalauréat qui arrivait
à l'université et des universités qui
n'était pas adapté pour accueillir
effectivement tous ces nouveaux
bacheliers qui arrivés en nombre
c'est à la suite de ça qui est arrivé le
projet université 2000 pour développer
un certain de sites universitaires
partout en france des restructurations
entière et pour effectivement permettre
à ce que ce soit pas simplement un
massacre à l'arrivée dans l'université
mais de donner les conditions de réussir
vous n'avez pas découvert l'engagement
et la politique à à l'arrivée à la fac
c'était un truc de famille chez vous non
j'ai une famille qui a eu ses
engagements je crois que comme dans
toute famille et tout en gardant les
secrets de famille et individuel je
crois voilà je toujours assez pudique
sûr sûr sûr ce qu'a pu être ma vie mais
vous savez on peut aussi parfois on a
tous passé par des moment de
l'adolescence avec des à la fois la
volonté de faire pareil se sont
démarqués donc oui bien sûr j'ai grandi
dans une famille où où l'engagement
politique l'engagement communiste a
toujours été très présent avec des
débats parfois très passionné parfois
même un peu violent comme on sait faire
dans les repas de famille en france
fromage mais donc voilà avec à la fois
une volonté forcément des idées
transmise mais en tout cas à cet âge là
plutôt une volonté effectivement de
faire je fais du syndicalisme étudiant
me disant que je ne voulais pas
forcément faire de la politique dans un
parti et prendre des responsabilités en
tout cas alors à propos de partie il ya
cent le tyran dans le chat qui nous dit
normalement après l'unef ont pas au ps
pas au pcf alors ça c'est d'abord
d'avoir je crois que c'est mal connaître
l'histoire du syndicalisme étudiant je
dis je le disais il y avait deux unef il
y avait eu l'unef il y avait l'unef id
donc chacun il y avait ces sensibilités
peut-être le reste en tout cas convaincu
que pour ma part j'ai milité avec des
étudiants qui n'étaient pas forcément
d'ailleurs adhérents des partis
politiques et le syndicalisme se doit de
garder cette indépendance même s'il a pu
aller proximité d'esprit et donc non
effectivement je n'ai pas rejoint le
parti socialiste comme je viens de le
voir passer dans le tchat
effectivement j'ai aussi fait partie des
mobilisations contre un certain ministre
de l'éducation nationale de l'époque
notamment claude allègre qui a qui a
utilisé l'expression qui fait dégraisser
le mammouth
à l'heure où on nous demandions
justement plus de moyens pour
l'éducation nationale et notamment
enseignement supérieur pour permettre
que j'étais tout à l'heure à toutes et
tous de réussir
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
envisagiez pas particulièrement de faire
une carrière politique et pourtant c'est
ce qui vous est arrivé
vous avez été élu ou c'est ce que vous
avez fait en tout cas vous avez été élu
une première fois en 2004 et de fil en
aiguille on va en reparler mais vous
êtes aujourd'hui sénatrice
c'est votre deuxième mandat vous
projetiez pas du tout dans une carrière
politique élective comme ça non d'abord
je pense qu'on ne fait pas de carrière
politique je pense qu'on a des
responsabilités politiques qui certes
peuvent s'enchaîner pavani a exercé
différents mandats mais une carrière à
l'ol sont construits elle se prévoir oui
j'avais prévu de faire une carrière
d'enseignante et d'ailleurs je me disais
j'ai passé un concours j'étais
professeur stagiaire qui est professeur
titulaire j'ai encadré des jeunes
professeur dans l'accompagnement aux
débuts dans le métier donc ma carrière
est le professionnel carrière et les
professionnels je ne pense pas que en
tout cas elles soient politiques
après effectivement j'ai je me dis
toujours et avec beaucoup d'humilité
d'abord j'ai fait le choix 1 pour finir
mes études de quitter la région car est
parisienne également pour échapper aussi
un peu à tout ce monde que que nous
évoquions cette pesanteur parfois même
d'un engagement étudiant d'un engagement
familial
et puis voilà peut-être qu'à écouter les
réalités nous ramène se rappelle plus
vite à nous que nous voudrions j'ai
aussi bénéficié bon - le premier mandat
est au conseil régional en 2004 pas
d'une époque où d'abord à la loi sur la
parité vient d'être votée donc il ya une
réalité pour toutes les formations
politiques c'est de faire des listes à
parité avec autant d'hommes que de
femmes issus d'un parti qui a toujours
valoriser l'engagement des femmes et qui
à ce moment là c'est fait un choix à
travers les élections régionales de 2004
de renouveler également très fortement
ses élus et de faire place à la jeunesse
donc voilà non pas que je cache les plus
non pas la natation n'est pas que je ne
te nièce que ce que je suis et je ne
sais pas simplement voilà une addition
de bonnes cases cochées pour pouvoir
être élu mais voilà je
j'arrive aussi en politique avec ces
données là qui pour moi mais comme plein
d'autres collègues d'ailleurs à gauche
comme à droite permet à des jeunes
femmes à l'époque d'avoir des
responsabilités dans les collectivités
alors vous avez parlé de jeunes femmes
vous avez été saynètes élue sénatrice la
première fois en 2011
vous aviez 35 ans vous étiez la
benjamine du sénat la plus jeune
sénatrice
racontez nous comment ça c'est ce qu'on
arrive autre nom mais justement dans mes
raconter nos ça se passe comment quand
on a 35 ans et qu'on débarque au sénat
mais écoutez moi y évoquer mon passé de
syndicaliste étudiante je ne connaissais
le sénat que côté rue voilà
déjà deux ans mais n'avait jamais
franchi la porte et donc ne s'est jamais
passé côté cour
j'avais donc un plus cette appréhension
effectivement de qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière ces portes et donc non membres
ça avait très très naturellement je suis
arrivé bon bien évidemment je crois que
les huissiers m'attendait pour pour me
voilà deux présentes et allemand ce qui
allait se passer donc j'étais présent
chars et puis effectivement quelques
jours après quand on est benjamin jamie
participe en tant que tel à l'opération
de l'élection du président du sénat
ce set ce titre-là de dure que quelques
quelques heures cela il faut plutôt
faire ses preuves
faire la démo jeunes on a toute sa place
dans cet hémicycle
est ce que le cliché selon lequel le
sénat c'est un truc de vieux hommes est
vrai est ce qu'il était vraiment 2011
est ce que c'est une impression que ça
vous à faire est ce que ça a changé
depuis ma question
ça a fortement changé depuis à 2011 en
me levant le sénat s'est profondément
transformé le président du sénat
rappeler a maintenant deux ans que ça va
peut-être faire rire certains mais je
crois qu'ils en 2000 après le
renouvellement de 2017
il y avait seulement un tiers des
sénateurs et sénatrices élus en 2011
nous avons donc voyons peut être un jour
très jeunes et quelques années après
rejoindre le camp quand même des anciens
qu'il s'est profondément transformé mais
avec ce que je sais c'est à dire que ma
génération est d'ailleurs même celle
d'avant mais mais mais mais mais ces
femmes ce renouvellement politique que
l'on observe dans les communes dans les
départements dans les régions
inévitablement fini par arriver au sénat
parce que nous sommes les représentants
des collectivités territoriales est
aujourd'hui certes il ya toujours plus
d'hommes que de femmes au sénat certes
mais on retrouve finalement une image du
sénat qui est à l'image de ce que sont
les élus locaux d'ailleurs peut-être
avec un peu plus de femmes aux
responsabilités au sénat comment les
collectivités territoriales un vrai
rajeunissement en tout cas ça ou ça
c'est certain et je trouve
voilà la caricature qui était déjà une
caricature quand je suis arrivé en 2011
n'a plus du tout lieu d'être aujourd'hui
du hockey vieil homme aux cheveux blancs
boitant et c'est moi déjà je les appelle
vu en arrivant en 2011 parce qu'il y
avait son renouvellement de 2011 et aux
après les le renouvellement de 2014 2017
et jeudi je pense que celui de 2020
perdre voilà fera voir des jeunes
sénateurs réélus mais un certain nombre
ne se représenteront pas et du coup ceux
ci à se renouveler et je pense que parce
que voilà c'est important aussi
vous êtes sénatrice du coup depuis 2009
vous siéger au sein du groupe crc eux
qui veut dire communistes républicains
citoyens écologistes
si tu peux te et donc on en parlait de
votre engagement voilà vous êtes vous
êtes sénatrice communiste et évidemment
ça fait toujours beaucoup réagir ça veut
dire quoi être communiste
en 2000 j'ai écouté tous là je le sais
parce que je suis sénatrice communiste
je suis un communiste sénatrice et je
tiens à le préciser parce que c'est
différent je pense que je vais
d'ailleurs je suis sénatrice de mon
département je suis à infuser la loire
je crois que les les électeurs dans mon
département sont loin d'être des
électeurs tous kunis et son site je
crois que dans ma règle soit ils ont
aussi reconnu le travail du quotidien de
proximité donc plus que la division
partisane dans un vote il ya aussi eu le
choix d'une personne par contre
effectivement et je n'ai jamais nié et
mes engagements sont affichées je suis
également commis je crois qu'être
communiste aujourd'hui en 2020 c'est
d'être finalement attaché à la question
bien évidemment les valeurs de la gauche
les valeurs progressistes des valeurs de
transformation sociale qui reste plus
que jamais d'actualité et de choix de
société qui font que effectivement un
bar pour prendre les questions qui sont
aujourd'hui posée et qui vont être
devant nous par exemple du développement
économique comment de cette sortie de
crise le développement est indispensable
on le on le travaille on va en parler
des hommes de de développer plus
d'égalité ou au contraire d'un
développement économique qui demain
renforcera les inégalités donc bien
évidemment les personnes qui travaillent
doivent être rémunérés je ne suis pas
pour nier les différences entre les
travail ou les différents niveaux de
revenus mais il ya très certainement
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de choses
à revoir je crois que cette notion du
partage partage des richesses elles
restent plus que jamais dans notre pays
d'actualité parce que paradoxalement
dans un pays aussi riche les inégalités
n'ont jamais été aussi forte
alors justement vous êtes communiste et
y ait beaucoup de questions qui ont été
posées pour vous sur l'actualité
justement et on va commencer par part
justement ce que vous venez de dire une
question de yoplait qui vous demandent
est ce que les luttes antiracistes
empiète sur la lutte des classes non
d'abord je ne pense pas parce que je
pense que elles sont complémentaires il
nous faudrait justement j'ai grandi dans
une famille où la lutte contre
l'apartheid a été très très importante
voilà et peut-être que à mes engagements
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je fais de la
politique qui me fait croire à mon
engagement même quand le temps est
difficile c'est que voilà je me souviens
petit jeune adolescente d'un mail sonne
mandela qui était le prisonnier
politique le plus vieux du monde est
donc même si une action pour sa
libération
l'interrogation était quand même s'il
allait en jean sortie de prison il a été
libéré et ce jour là je m'en souviens
encore parce que justement ce qui peut
penser impossible un certain moment nous
devient donc voilà
ce combat ce que je veux dire c'est que
voilà ce combat contre le racisme
il a toujours existé l'a toujours existé
chez les communistes et il continuera
d'exister
par contre je crois qu'il faut qu'une
passion attention en france ailleurs
d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays oui je
reste convaincu que l'analyse sociale
reste importante et que c'est celle-ci
qui prime
parce que l'on a tendance de plus en
plus a analysé notre société en fonction
des communautés mais mais mais cela ne
pose pas justement cette question
fondamentale qui est celle de la
répartition des de la richesse sa voix
auprès de différentes origines
ce qui fait que l'on qui bien ou pas
c'est quand même sa place au travail
ensuite il ya la question du rat alors
justement la question du racisme qui est
parti quand d'actualité actuellement
avec la avec les manifestations black
ice matters et le et en france également
les violences policières enfin là c'est
vraiment d'actualité en ce moment il ya
aussi une question qui vous étaient qui
vous étiez posée par par le même
internaute d'ailleurs qui vous demande
qu'est ce que vous pensez du
déboulonnage des statuts et des
graffitis sur les statuts moi je suis
peut-être que là c'est mon métier de
professeur d'histoire géographie qui
revient je pense que nous déboulonne pas
les statuts voilà je je je pense
qu'elles sont elles sont révélatrices
en tout cas d'une difficulté que nous
avons avec notre histoire et quand on
déboulonne quelque chose c'est que
finalement d'abord l'on fait fi de ce
qu'il a été
et j'oublie on a un souci en france -
ajout de la guerre d'algérie vous savez
il a fallu attendre le début des années
moi j'ai moi j'ai commencé à enseigner
dans les manuels d'histoire géographie
de classe de troisième
on ne parlait pas de la guerre d'algérie
ont parlé des incidents l'algérie voilà
j'ai arrêté d'enseigner quand je suis
devenue sénatrice on parlait de la
guerre d'algérie donc voilà si vous
voulez jeu
c'est ça aussi notre histoire donc la
question aujourd'hui elle n'est pas de
servir de déboulonner ou de d'idéaliser
d'icônes ise tel ou tel voilà je pense
que la question elle est de prendre
conscience de notre histoire et elle est
surtout qu'ils jour de se forger une
histoire commune que nous ne nous
forgeons plus parce que et je le redis
un des dangers notamment des
communautarismes en tout genre c'est
justement celui ci c'est justement celui
ci c'est de ce sale et moi je la la être
citoyen français c'est vivre avec
avec ce n'est pas ce n'est pas s'opposer
les uns aux autres et donc c'est en tout
cas ce à quoi aujourd'hui nous sommes
confrontés est le vrai danger est
peut-être effectivement voilà le
nationalisme c'est la haine de l'autre
le patriotisme le patriotisme c'est
l'amour des siens et je crois que cette
cette formule reste toujours d'actualité
parce que ce ne sont pas que des mots
mais aujourd'hui plus que des valeurs -
je vois ici dans mon département nous le
voit de partout on a tendance plus à
regarder ce que notre n'a pas à se
diviser plutôt qu'à se dire qu'ensemble
nous pourrions être plus forts et nous
pourrons nous pourrions obtenir plus
pour chacun alors vous parlez
patriotisme il ya des émirats qui se
révèle qu patriotisme qui sont choqués
par une proposition qui a été faite par
jean luc mélenchon et c'est une question
qui vous appeler papa qui vous est posée
par mr sy qui vous de nous qui vous
demande faut-il désarmer la police comme
le propose dans les planches ont pas
écoutés je vous propose de poser la
pétition d'abord et vous votre nom et
non pas désarmer la police met
d'ailleurs dans les cas aujourd'hui dans
les cas qui sont compris devant la
justice
donc dix cas de plainte pour violence
judiciaire la la la justice dira ce
qu'il en est ce n'est pas forcément un
problème d'armes à feu donc la question
de la violence dans notre société
s'il suffisait d' interdire les armes
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de violence ça
se saurait et aujourd'hui on a un
certain nombre d'actes de violence mais
au delà même des violences policières
des citoyens entre eux tout ceci n'est
pas une question d'armes donc la
question des arts loi reste est bien
évidemment ne doit pas être généralisée
elle doit être utilisé avec précaution
il faut bien évidemment je pense
beaucoup plus de ce qu'il faut faire
beaucoup plus de formation beaucoup plus
de formations régulières notamment parce
que c'est mais on est aujourd'hui dans
une société de plus en plus violentes et
donc est toute la question avec la
police gens croient au delà de savoir
s'il faut désarmer ou pas désarmer la
police c'est surtout comment est-ce que
l'on redonne toute sa place à une police
qui est là pour protéger et qui n'est
pas là pour que l'on ait peur voilà on
s'est donc c'est tout le débat de la
police de proximité de 2 mètres aussi
plus de moyens très certainement moi je
pense d'organiser déroulement dans un
certain nombre d'équipements que ce ne
soit pas toujours les mêmes personnes
qui au bout de dix ans soit dans les
mêmes endroits de blaye il y à tout ça à
retravailler à repenser pour qu'il y ait
une réelle police qui soit une police de
protection et non pas une police qui
effectivement aujourd'hui et c'est une
réalité et je ne dis pas que c'est c'est
volontaire mais pour laquelle un certain
nombre de jeunes ne se sentent pas
toujours à l'aise et la police c'est une
partie de la société avec l'effectif en
a comme tout le monde
come on to corps ddd des brebis galeuses
sur lesquels il faut aujourd'hui que
l'inspection générale se penche et qu'il
puisse y avoir les sanctions quand effet
à ceux reconnus
on va parler on va parler de l'actualité
plus institutionnelle puisque cette
semaine aussi on à voile a découvert les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat les 150 citoyens tirés au
sort qui ont travaillé depuis neuf mois
sur voilà des solutions pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique ces
solutions elles sont sur la table tout
cas ces propositions elles sont sur la
table
elles font grand bruit est ce que vous
les avez lu non je n'étais pas toute nue
encore voilà très très honnêtement
moi je veux dire deux choses d'abord
faut pas oublier quelque chose c'est que
le présent n'applique nous avait vendu
sa à la sortie de la crise des gilet
jaune et il me semble que ou alors
seulement dans la loire il ya eu des
ronds points particuliers mais je ne
pense pas pourquoi elle y compris me
déplacer régulièrement dans la région
vers le grenat donc au moins dans 12
départements de france que la question
des exigences et des revendications si
s'exprimer sur les ronds points mais au
delà dans toute la société à travers
cela ne portait pas que sur la question
environnementale
oui c'est un vrai défi il faut le
relever ensemble la question des défis
climatiques
la question de la transition énergétique
mais ça ne suffira pas à ce que demain
l'on vive mieux ça ne suffira pas à ce
que demain dans les zones rurales
la fermeture des services publics fait
que aujourd'hui pour pour avoir accès à
un hôpital ça devient compliqué donc
c'est quel est le rapport donc avec
commençons citoyenne pour le coup parce
que là est la réponse qui a été fait sur
la crise du gilet jaune
je pense que elle ne suffira pas et le
gouvernement ne veut pas simplement
aujourd'hui se draper dans une lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique pour
faire oublier les revendications
sociales qui se sont fortes et de
justice au prix d'égalité qui se sont
exprimés en l'occurrence la convention
citoyenne pour le climat avait pour
mission de proposer des voies là des
propositions dans des propositions pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
dans un esprit de justice sociale et
c'était très important pour eux
d'ailleurs la commission citoyenne n'a
pas proposé le retour de la taxe carbone
précisément pour cette raison la scène
la taxe qui avait déclenché le mouvement
des filets jaunes
le mouvement des gilets jaunes beaucoup
de critiques se sont fait entendre
contre les critiques contre les
propositions la convention citoyenne
notamment comme étant des propositions
propre à gauche trop punitive
on pense notamment à l'interdiction de
rouler à plus de 110 km heure sur les
autoroutes à une proposition qui a été
faite mais qui finalement n'a pas été
voté par la convention qui était la
semaine de 28 heures de travail payées
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
climat particulier autour de cette
convention citoyenne qu'elle est trop
politisé
est-ce que vous pensez que ces
propositions sont trop peu trop abrupte
je ne pense pas d'accord parce que la
façon dont ont été tirés au sort les
différents citoyens
voilà je suis pas rentré dans le détail
mais se veut un panel représentatif ça
monte plusieurs choses ça monte qui
d'abord que quand on sort là les
différents citoyens de de ce quotidien
ils peuvent réfléchir prendre le temps
de réfléchir faire des propositions
ensuite effectivement sur la question qu
nitivement je me suis pas favorable à
l'abaissement de 130 à 110 km/heure sur
les autoroutes mais lac cette question
là par exemple elle et elle est elle
renvoie les citoyens dans la difficulté
de l'exercice mais j'ai envie de dire
d'efforts à la difficulté de l'exercice
que nous connaissons en tant que
parlementaire bien fait en politique
fait qu'est ce que l'on fait si l'on ne
nous donne pas plus de moyens
voilà et donc y'a un bandeau et les
citoyens dans la convention citoyenne se
retrouve face à une difficulté c'est que
si par exemple sur la question
d'abaisser de 130 à 110 kilomètres pour
rester dans le concret deux solutions
vous allez de dire aujourd'hui si je
roule à 130 ces polluants vous avez
l'autre solution qui est de dire il faut
investir massivement
merci ventes compris dans notre
économique dans la recherche pour que
d'ici à dix ans on est des voitures qui
ne pollue pas moi je crois ne sont pas
antinomiques mais ça coûte plus cher
cercle ça me coûte rien entre guillemets
ça ne coûte rien aujourd'hui
si ce n'est changement des panneaux de
dire on va rouler de 130 à 110 c'est bon
pour la planète que ceux d'hier à 5 10
ans on m'investit très massivement à
recherche publique on y met les moyens
en lien avec notre industrie automobile
et compris relance rayons x x et de la
production de richesse dans le pays pour
avoir des voitures qui peuvent être
moins polluantes dans dix ans - je crois
que des finales peut être les mets quoi
voilà la convention citoyenne et les
armando est contrainte de faire des
propositions dans
une situation qui est celle des choix
budgétaires de ce gouvernement
ouais en l'occurrence en l'occurrence
ici sont allé franco sur les sur les
propositions et d'ailleurs ce que vous
dites c'est exactement ce qu'ils ont dit
investissements massifs dans le dans la
transformation énergétique baisse de la
vitesse des véhicules mais surtout
renouvellement du parc de véhicules ont
dit y a pas non plus à graver dans la
question énergétique
toute la question du service public
n'est pas imposée moi je pense que par
exemple si on reste dans un système
concurrentiel tel que celui
d'aujourd'hui
tout ceci restera très certainement que
développer à la aux ambitions est ce que
est ce que vous pensez qu emmanuel
macron va aller jusqu'au référendum le
chef de l'état reçoit les citoyens lundi
pour leur dire ce qui voilà ce qui va
faire de la suite de leurs travaux il a
déjà à plusieurs reprises évoqué la
possibilité de soumettre à référendum
des propositions je suis désolé vous
pensez qu'ils devraient le faire je ne
sais pas ce qu'il va faire d'abord il ya
plusieurs choses sur la question qui a
beaucoup fait débat de l'éco cid raines
reconnaître effectivement comme un crime
qui tout ce qui peut nuire à
l'environnement et au climat
on est sur un registre l'acquis de selon
notre constitution s'apparente à la même
proposition qui avait été faite en son
temps de suppression de la peine de
l'abolition de la peine de mort pardon
et donc ça ne peut pas passer par
référendum
et ça ça passe par effectivement entre
un travail législatif des deux chambres
assemblée nationale et sénat sur
d'autres sujets bien évidemment il le
peut la donc dire aujourd'hui ce qui
fera ou ce qu'il ne fera pas là encore
et je vais je redis avec beaucoup de
précaution je pense que le référendum
est une fin ultime quand il ya eu un
travail législatives quand il ya un
débat à trancher un référendum ne peut
pas être utilisé pour se dorer la pilule
quand on est en difficulté politique
face à la politique que l'on mène donc
on ne peut pas d'un côté vous voyez
avoir fait le 49-3 sur la réforme des
retraites nous dire en plein confinement
qu'on suspend la réforme des
être nous la faire à l'envers en sortie
de déconfinement est en train de
préparer le retour de la réforme des
retraites non c'est pas quand elle va
quand même revenir et puis à l'issue de
tous à faire un référendum pour dire que
tout va bien dans notre pays
voilà je crois que le référendum est un
acte qui doit être utilisé avec
parcimonie dans la vème république et
quand il laisse effectivement pour
convoquer le peuple sur des décisions
importantes qui concernent qui engage
plusieurs plusieurs années au delà du
temps du quinquennat donc j'avais dire
il fera ce qu'il fera ce qu'il voudra
même mais il faut toujours faire
attention parce que parfois à court
terme cela peut servir mais s'amuser
avec les statuts et les institutions
parfois même les dévoyer ça se retourne
toujours contre soi un moment donné
alors vous parlez des voiliers des
institutions et c'est très intéressant
puisque la convention citoyenne pour le
climat indépendamment de ces
propositions est aussi très critiqué sur
sa forme elle même
le tirage au sort provoque des levées de
boucliers parmi un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui y voit une menace
contre leur légitimité je pense
notamment à votre collègue les
républicains jean marc boyer qui hier à
l'occasion des questions au gouvernement
voilà fait une attaque en règle contre
ses citoyens qui ressort en disant
qu'ils ne sont pas légitimes
etc qu'est ce que vous en tant que
parlementaire force et du courage au
sort non je ne suis pas opposé par
principe au tirage au sort dès lors
c'est ce que je disais qu'il respecte
une comme comme dans un sondage une
représentativité à tout juste possible
d'un échantillon de la société
deuxièmement le le vrai souci est
peut-être l'incompréhension mais qui lie
avec la convention citoyenne
c est ce qu'à un moment donné on fait
travailler pour faire des propositions
et les mettre en débat
est ce qu'on les fait travailler pour
décider ou pas et en fait je sais la
ligne de 2 c la feuille de route qui qui
qui n'est pas très clair c'est le
dialogue y compris peut-être avec les
parlementaires dans ce que l'on attend
de cette convention citoyenne et de la
feuille de route qu'on lui donne qui n'a
par exemple pas été discuté avec les
parlementaires et on pourrait trouver
par exemple
pertinent que l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat débattent de cette feuille de
route pour que les citoyens ensuite tiré
au sort puis ce voile à travailler en
toute liberté
mais avec le regard de la diversité
politique et des territoires qui sont
représentés à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat ce n'a pas été le cas
deuxièmement je pense tout de même il
faut dire avec un port était que le
confinement est passée par là et que
entre guillemets cette convention
citoyenne est revenu sans que personne
ne l'ait vu revenir
moi je mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai oui ce fait je ne sais trop quel
était son but de départ son objectif de
fin c'est son pouvoir entre guillemets
et ce qu'elle devait faire ou ne pas
faire
- par contre j'ai été très attentive le
dimanche soir quand ils ont remis leurs
travaux il y avait plusieurs personnes
qui était interrogé sur différents
médias radios ou télévisées et 2 3 ont
bien dit il y a des choses que nous
n'avons pas tranché
parce que ce n'est pas notre ce n'est
pas de notre ressort
sassou seront à celles et ceux qui
doivent faire la loi de décider et donc
il y a des propositions qui aujourd'hui
sont mises sur la table que nous voulons
voir grandir dans le débat citoyen dans
le débat législatif mais nous n'avons
pas fait de proposition de loi en tant
que tel ça c'est le travail des
parlementaires et donc je pense que on a
travaillé cette complémentarité mais
finalement finalement c'est bien ce
qu'on fait au quotidien quand on est élu
par mois excuse moi tu es élu la
première chose que je fais c'est
discuter avec les associations et
concitoyens ex qui va le voir en tant
que cinéaste ismaël rencontrer les élus
aujourd'hui dans mon département j'ai
centre un nouveau maire mais ma priorité
c'est cet été de pouvoir aller à la
rencontre de chacun pour échanger sur
leurs projets etc
donc oui ce temps des changes il est
indispensable dans la vie politique et
peut-être que nationalement la après il
faudra pas se tromper c'est que la crise
de la politique dans notre pays et cette
cassure qu'il ya notamment entre les
citoyens et les parlementaires que nous
sommes dans notre diversité
elle va pas se résoudre à plus de
convention citoyenne
ça je n'y crois pas et donc il faut
faire attention là encore c'est ce que
je disais à ne pas renvoyer le sentiment
qu'avec une convention citoyenne
tout ça est réglé et tout le monde a
confiance dans tout le monde et upi
tralala on est reparti tout va bien je
pense que malheureusement cette crise
demeure plus importante que cela est-ce
que sk l'occasion d'une réforme de la
constitution vous seriez favorable à ce
qu'on a ce qu'on institue à ce qu on
institutionnalise le tirage au sort
comme étant justement un allié comme
vous le dites des parlementaires pour
travailler faire des propositions
réfléchir ça a été proposée par certains
de vos collègues députés qui ont même
dit qu'ils étaient favorables à ce que
le tirage au sort fasse son entrée à
l'assemblée nationale via des citoyens
qui viendraient filer un coup de main
aux députés sur leurs travaux pas qu'ils
seraient pas qu'ils seraient qui
deviendrait parlement je pense
aujourd'hui il ya les moyens pour faire
ce type de convention dont il n'a pas
besoin de faire rentrer y'a pas besoin
de faire rentrer ce qui existe déjà en
fait c'est fait je crois pourtant que ça
c'est une réalité
moi je suis quand même pour toujours que
la loi puisse être souple la posture
puis cette soudure justement permettre
ce type d'initiative
deuxièmement il faut faire attention
parce que si l'on pense que l'on va
régler le problème de la crise politique
en ignorant les puisque ce sont aussi
les partis politiques
7 c'est un souci parce que bien manger
les partis politiques sont décriés mais
à l'origine
et s'ils sont reconnus comme un des
acteurs démocratique dans la
constitution
c'est aussi justement parce que la
citoyenneté le contrôle et il se fait
par groupe
voilà et donc faire de la politique au
sens se diriger la cité collectivement
ce n'est pas une addition d'individus ce
sont des projets ce sont les femmes et
des hommes qui les défendent
et cela doit se faire ensemble et moins
je ne souhaite pas que demain la
politique soit une individualisation à
l'image de ce que l'on peut voir parfois
dans la société et que cela reste une
dynamique collective et donc
effectivement je crois la proposition
que j'ai vu passer n'importe quel député
aujourd'hui peut travailler avec des
citoyens sur n'importe quelle proposé
sur moi moi mon collègue ans
les chats c'est la proposition de loi
sur les retraités agricoles que j'avais
défendu au sénat quand elle était
arrivée au sénat va il a travaillé la
rue mise en ligne de ce syndicat la
déconne il a travaillé avec eux donc je
viens moi quand la loi engagement et
proximité sur la question des élus
passée jérémy pas j'ai fait une dizaine
de rayon dans mon département pour
revenir les élus et travailler avec eux
j'ai pas besoin de deux cartes de loi
pour qu'on me dise qu être élu c'est
travailler avec l'autre ouais je je et
puis vous vous sentez menacés dans votre
dans votre légitimité par des citoyens
tirés au sort je dis ça parce que je
sais ça fait deux ans maintenant que
j'ai une période et sénateurs des
sénatrices et à chaque fois je me sens
que je sens que vous vous sentez menacés
car je pense que c'est bien pire que
c'est moi je crois moi je me sens menacé
par rien du tout je pense que par contre
la démocratie ce n'est pas le tirage ou
sans voile à la démocratie ce sont des
îles et ce sont ces du débat c'est de la
construction il n'ya pas de génération
spontanée donc on ne s'improvise pas
voilà c'est il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
deux on leur fait des études
n'importe qui tout le monde peut faire
de la politique mais cela se construit
et ceux là qu'on se construit avec
l'autre et donc le souci du tirage au
sort d'un non pas dans ce qu'il a été la
force de proposition mon ange mais dans
ce qui pourrait être demain une
assemblée nationale c'est que du coup on
est plus sur un débat et des programmes
on n'est plus la construction d'une
société a pris à plus ou moins long
terme
on est plus sur des projets que l'on
porte que l'on défend que l'on explique
voilà et donc ne faudrait pas donner à
croire que la démocratie c'est
l'addition d'intérêts particuliers la
démocratie c'est la défense de l'intérêt
général
donc moi je suis je me sens menacé par
un plein d'autres choses à faire dans ma
vie si demain estime non non non non ce
serait pour couronner ce que je veux
dire c'est que mes parcours en ce que la
la
la démocratie française au sens où
l'entend et donc la fin de l'élection
c'est tout si la fin hs de de vrais
débats des noms mais personne ne propose
pas mais c'est vraiment intéressant
parce que je sens vraiment que la
convention citoyenne est venue perturber
beaucoup de parlementaires dans toutes
ces réflexions là précisément et je
trouve ça particulièrement intéressant
et je ne vous cache pas que les
internautes qui qui regarde mes
émissions et qui regarde sa question et
sénateurs sont un peu plus à un peu plus
intéressés par la compare la convention
citoyenne et par le tirage au sort que
par le sénat
probablement pour des questions de
clichés mais même avant les questions
qui vous avez dans une société qui
aujourd'hui est en crise
face à un certain nombre d'élus qui ont
fait qu'ils sont marginaux mais en
nombre mais qui ont fait la une de
l'actualité depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années
forcément oui bien sûr oui les élus sont
mal vus dans notre pays message en deuil
avec vous internautes en sais quoi je
viens d'entendre cette année - je veux
dire j'ai pas besoin d'aller d'aller
plus loin donc oui ça c'est une réalité
la question c'est est ce que pour
pallier sa on répond uniquement par la
convention citoyenne ou pas et donc moi
je ne pense pas mais je vous dis je
pense que la question finalement de
l'individu et du collectif voilà alors
peut-être que dans un pays où il est
passé de trop de collectif a trop
l'individu qui a certainement
aujourd'hui à à retrouver un juste
milieu mais je le redis je pense que
l'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas faire
vivre démocratie s'il n'y a pas de
collectif qui respecte chacun est alors
assez parlante
en parlant de l'institution il y en a
une qui a une spécificité c'est les
territoires et celle sénat ça tombe bien
je voulais pas en parler avec vous pour
le coup on va on va parler on va parler
de territoires vous l'aviez vous l'avez
dit vous êtes élue régionale en rhône
alpes vous êtes sénatrice le scénario du
territoire j'ai dit quoi j'ai dit rona
par drogba
attention les auvergnats pardon les
auvergnats je suis navré vraiment désolé
voilà emmanuel macron dans son
allocution la télévision a parlé d'un
nouvel acte de décentralisation même
s'il n'a pas prononcé le mot tout le
monde l'a compris il a il a l'intention
de revenir dessus dans l'est dans les
semaines qui viennent et de et de faire
des propositions
est-ce que vous est ce que vous pensez
qu'on va avoir besoin des régions pour
construire le plan de relance et la
lutte contre la crise
on va avoir besoin des régions des
départements et les communes ont besoin
des trois échange d'activités mon jeu je
ne pose aucun aucune à l'autre jeu
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
nouvelle décentralisation est ce qu'on
en a besoin
bien sûr mais on va avoir besoin mais
parce qu on vient d'avoir la
démonstration que qu'on a besoin des
collectivités territoires en période de
crise on a besoin des collectivités
territoriales qui au plus près on
suggérer qui dans la distribution de
repas pour les personnes isolées ou
médicaments qui pour l'approvisionnement
en masques pour le grand public qui dans
le soutien et l'accompagnement social
donc chacun bien évidemment dans son
rôle dans la tente en l'accompagnement
notamment des petites entreprises d'où
toute l'organisation de la sous
traitance bref on vit quand on vient de
vivre et on continue de vivre le fait
que l'on a besoin des collectivités
territoriales et donc la question de ce
nouvel acte de la décentralisation
c est ce que est ce que maintenant
lourds eux d'abord est ce que l'on
redonne le pouvoir notamment aux
départements et aux régions pour leur a
supprimé à savoir ce qu'on appelle la
clause de compétence générale c'est à
dire justement cette capacité à pouvoir
agir et notamment pas de prise sans
qu'il y ait de domaine de compétence
exclusive qui bien souvent on range les
gens dans des cases et quand quand il ya
une crise il faudrait un peu plus de
fluidité il celle ci on ne l'a pas payé
actuellement
vous travaillez actuellement d'ailleurs
sur sur un rapport sur le sujet des
départements de la place des
départements dans l'est dans les régions
dans les grandes métropoles
il ya une question qui vous est posée
par l'arpp un qui veut savoir est ce que
dans son nouvel acte vous pensez pas qu
emmanuel macron va en profiter pour
terminer ce qu'il a commencé et
supprimer totalement les départements
dans ces régions là qu est ce que vous
l'avez jamais fait ça conseiller ou
renoncer moi il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
le département est sauvée compris
l'expérience que l'on a que l'on peut
voir à michel notamment de la métropole
de lyon n'est pas même pas concluante et
ça faisait ce qui à un moment donné on
se sont dit qu'il pourrait faire pareil
ils n'ont plus envie
donc voila moi je vous prends en tout
cas que nous avons besoin des
départements besoins des départements et
j'en ai malheureusement conflit parce
que semblerait que cette compétence
sociale qu'ils ont et qu'ils exercent
comme par hasard personne ne la souhaite
aujourd'hui donc de toutes les façons je
crois qe département resteront je pense
qu'on a besoin d'eux et encore plus
voilà c'est vous disiez le rapport que
que que je travaille en ce moment mais
dans ces grandes régions qui ont
fusionné parler de ma région auvergne
grenade seilh sont douze départements du
sud du cantal au nord de la haute savoie
du nord de l'est au sud de l'ardèche
donc si vous voulez on a on a besoin de
cet échange entre la commune et la
région pour compris garantir de la
solidarité territoriale et sociale
il ya eu ue qui pardon qui vous prennent
qui vous demandent est ce que est ce que
vous réflexion sur la décentralisation
concerne aussi la réorganisation des
pouvoirs politiques au niveau local
c'est à dire excuse
dr b entre régions départements mairie
faut-il lui faut-il une nouvelle
organisation des pouvoirs politiques une
nouvelle démocratie ou est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on continue comme actuellement bas il
ya plusieurs choses
moi je viens de le dire est ce que je
pourrais demander pour ceux qui nous
écoutent de préciser ce que veut dire la
clause de compétence générale
la ssii précise tous les domaines c'est
à dire par exemple pour les régions ne
pas être simplement sur la question
économique lycées transports formation
qui sont quatre grands chantiers pour le
département l'action sociale les
collèges et les routes
voilà pour pour donner des exemples mais
à l'image d'une commune de pouvoir agir
dans tous les champs l'on a gardé est ce
qu'on a appelé des compétences partagées
savoir pour le tourisme la culture mais
on a bien vu ba voilà par exemple à la
question de la santé que s'il y avait eu
la clause de compétence générale
très certainement il y aurait eu plus de
fluidité compris entre l'état et les
différentes collectivités
donc c'est ça ce qu'on appelle et
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est important
parce que ça va être peut-être rejoindre
le débat précédent mais elle permet
aussi d'avoir des vrais débats
politiques et des vrais projets des
démos de de gestion alors il va écouter
après des élections les gens choisissent
parfois les uns gagnent parfois les
autres perdent la vie politique est
ainsi fait et je crois que c'est
important
et puis alors par contre peut-être que
dans la question il y à aussi sur la
question de l'organisation du pouvoir
moi je suis pour que l'on maintienne le
nombre d'élus c'est ça la question je
pense que je ne souffre pas de trop
d'élus dans notre pays
je pense que justement une des premières
conditions pour réconcilier
finalement notre pays avec les élus et
la politique c'est que le plus grand
nombre d'entre nous puisse exercer un
mandat un mandat
électif par contre il ya certainement à
redonner plus de facilité à agir
alors là c'est là tout devient compliqué
bien évidemment et qu'on est dans un
espèce de château de cartes qui risquent
de tomber à chaque fois mais sert plus
de capacité à agir plus de capacités
financières mais il faut faire attention
une réelle à une chose c'est que nous
sommes je crois tout et tous attachés à
ce que le deuxième mot de notre devise
égalité continue d'exister dans notre
pays et de partout donc on voit bien que
il y a à la fois besoin de donner les
moyens pour agir plus et mieux
mais il y a dans le même temps et non
pas en même temps mais il lui a dans le
même temps le besoin qu'il y ait un état
qui garantisse réellement cette égalité
sociale et territoriale parce
qu'aujourd'hui selon là où on habite
et il ya des inégalités et selon ses
revenus
il ya des inégalités on approche petit à
petit la fin de cette émission si vous
avez des questions le chat c'est le
moment d'y aller pour pour ccq kerman
moi j'en ai une cavité poser tout à
l'heure et dont je reviens sur votre sur
votre engagement et votre parti
politique
que pensez-vous des alliances à horizon
est ce que le parti communiste français
va présenter un candidat est ce que vous
allez vous rapprocher à nouveau de la
france est soumise est ce que qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez vrai d'abord je pense
que la gauche est dans un mauvais état
parce que même s'ils ont même si les
sondages deux ans avant ne veulent rien
dire il me le dire en tout cas une chose
c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme vous faites
l'addition de tout ça même avec un seul
avec un seul candidat de gauche
on a revendu compte donc il ya même un
raid et je crois que donc avant de
parler de la question des alliances pour
et pour le coup ça le temps viendra je
pense qu'il n'y est pas encore il y as
besoin est en tout cas c'est ce que nous
défendrons 7 ce besoin de créer des
luttes communes de doit agir ensemble
c'est ça l'urgence et c'est à dire de
pouvoir être rassemblés sur des luttes
iliad aujourd'hui à clermont ferrand une
très forte mobilisation pour la défense
de luxe faire qu'une entreprise qui a
fermé qui produisait des de l'oxygène
pur
pour les hôpitaux il y avait aujourd'hui
j'en suis fier l'ensemble des formations
politiques de gauche qui étaient là pour
défendre cette ré industrialisation là
je crois que c'est comme en tout cas
c'est d'abord par ces actes là et c'est
sur quoi nous attendre les gens moins 30
jours en combien n'ont rien à la
question n'est pas d accord la question
oui non mais s'y opposent ensemble mais
justement en terme de proposer ensemble
ya une question qui est posée par park
rames ter accès mais c'est où le pcf
entre la france insoumise et toutes les
autres gauche c'est un peu compliqué de
s'y retrouver quand on quand on n'est
pas un militant entre toutes les offres
oui mais quand tu es gauche tout ça
parce que sans défense c'est tout ça bah
écoutez moi je veux bien sûr il ya eu
gauche avec plusieurs formations
politiques comme il ya une droite avec
plusieurs formations politiques
donc voila et la droite a toujours été
finalement très diverses
c'est ce qui fait parfois son handicap
et ses skis dans les meilleurs moments
de notre histoire pour ma part en tout
cas je veux juger ainsi à donner à
donner le mieux quand comme justement
quand ce qui peut apparaître comme un
morcellement et capables de se
rassembler de faire le même peuvent être
se rassembler il ya justement
aujourd'hui va nous sommes une des
formations politiques qui à la sortie
des élections municipales un nombre très
important des locales nous avons une
vision bien évidemment de politique qui
est ancrée dans les réalités
territoriales ont créé dans dans le
pouvoir communal ancrée dans la vie du
quotidien et donc nous ne sommes pas
simplement une formation politique qui
attend les élections présidentielle et
législatives ces élections politiques de
tous les jours de tous les combats et de
tous les pouvoirs et nous pensons qu'il
n'y a pas de grand et de petites
élections il n'y a pas de grandes et de
petites institutions il n'y a pas
simplement la rue simplement
les assemblées d'élus c'est cet ensemble
et c'est la présence dans l'ensemble de
ces lieux qui fera demain la possibilité
d'une crédibilité pour la gauche de
regagner dans notre pays
yahia car jean qui vous fait remarquer
que la gauche ne gagne que quand elle
est unie et qui du coup c'est ce que
vous dites d'ailleurs et qui du coup
vous demander ce que vous vous y croyez
vous à l'union de la gauche en 2022
jusqu'à présent si on vous avait dit que
la gauche était dans un sale état scène
son unité les particuliers savoir un
papier rouge une réalité mais non
dévoilé la question c'est qu'est ce que
mon appel contre la gauche et hui je
pense que elle elle doit pouvoir se
rassembler mais nous mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le vrai et parce que nous
l'avons vécu ces dernières années
le vrai défi qui va être relevé à gauche
c'est si elle sait sera sonnée elle ne
se rangera pas derrière l'un ou derrière
l'autre les uns les autres
on sort d'un quinquennat qui a été celui
de françois hollande qui a été un temps
qu'il est difficile parce qu'une
majorité de français à voter pour un
président en pensant qu'ils allaient
faire une politique de gauche et qu'il
n'a pas fait de politique de gauche au
sens large de ce que peut être la
politique de gauche notamment sur les
questions sociales le rapport au travail
etc
donc il ya aussi sa danseuse dans notre
pays qui pèse c'est à dire qu' une
partie pensent que de toutes les façons
la gauche n'a pas revenir au pouvoir
parce que quand tu as donc gagné tout ce
travail là à faire je suis en tout cas
convaincu que c'est avec l'ensemble de
ses forces parce que les grandes
périodes de notre histoire
on peut parler de 36 c'est très anciens
peut paraître 80 pour les plus jeunes
qui pensent que même 97 pour certains
qui nous écoutent c'est toujours très
ancien réservoir mais en tout cas c'est
quand la gauche a su se rassembler dans
sa diversité et en respectant les
différentes formations politiques
kalla su est la plus efficace et la plus
haute
là on a parlé des niveaux nationaux dans
vos exemples mais on aurait pu aussi
aller jusqu'au niveau local faut pas
oublier que la gauche unie ça fonctionne
aussi au niveau local il ya des
expériences qui vous inspirent
particulièrement en disant qu'au niveau
local ça a marché
bah écoutez je crois que dans un certain
nombre de communes
voilà je vais pas vous mettez tout mais
d'abord quand la gauche a été lui un
certain nombre de victoires ou de
confirmation à donner ressortant au lieu
d soir du premier tour
donc ça c'est une vérité mais je crois
que là aussi il faut pas se mentir faire
mist est toujours plus facile que quand
vous menez avec un seul à présenter
voilà après quand on fait de la
politique c'est comme quand on fait du
sport conserva que c'était avec du jeu
moi je suis dans un département très
footballistiques avec saint-etienne si
on pense que en prend un ballon dans la
main on va plus vite faut faire du
réduit à faire des bulles donc aux
élections municipales
on présente des lices c'est donc plus
facile de satisfaire tout le monde que à
les élections présidentiels ou
législatifs vous n'avez que avoir un
candidat et un suppléant donc voilà je
crois qu'il faut l'appréhender il faut
aussi se dire que nous sommes parfois
aux élections à deux tours et que
d'occuper un premier tour qui permet
d'avoir une offre politique diversifiée
et qui si elle sait se rassembler
derrière peut être plus fort toi
le souci c'est que bon j'ai vu passer là
dans un certain nombre de choses mais
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
avec avec un certain nombre de début
d'europe écologie les verts certains
sauts je pense très à gauche et avec
lesquels j'ai eu aucun souci pour
travailler je pense que pour d'autres
parfois les notions de service public de
responsabilité sociale et de place de
l'humain est un peu oublié ce débat là
il va nous traverser pendant les années
qui viennent
mais la meilleure façon pour que la
gauche se rassemble c'est effectivement
qu'elle se rassemblent dans dans
l'action et aidant des propositions
concrètes comme nous l'avons fait
d'ailleurs pas d'ailleurs su contre la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris
en tout cas moi sur le chat j'ai vu
passer koech herman 2022
merci beaucoup s'il quitte sharman merci
on verra merci beaucoup d'avoir d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci beaucoup
à vous d'avoir posez vos questions à
cécile cukierman merci beaucoup à vous
si vous nous avez écouté en podcast ou
regardez en replay sur public sénat le
canal 13 de la tnt je vous dis à très
bientôt dans questions aux sénateurs
châu à tous
[Musique]